this year i'm concentrating on health
it's a journey
but no i feel good after her year of
health
rebel wilson is facing a new challenge
you gotta keep hustling guys the 41 year
old actress discussed her successful 60
pound weight loss journey
on good morning america and detailed the
struggle
she now faces now the challenge is to
keep it off i've never successfully in
my life
i've lost a bit of weight here and there
but never kept it off
while the comedian was on a mission in
2020 to change her lifestyle
and prioritize health she explained how
emotional eating
is still something she battles with from
the nutrition from the exercising to
working on my emotional eating which
anybody who knows me knows is my real
advice
like seeing all the easter eggs out
there right now i'm like
oh um it's it's crazy
it's driving me crazy despite the new
challenges she faces
wilson is very focused and motivated
on the positives of her journey i'm
loving it and i'm really proud of myself
for being
being able in such a difficult year to
um
to do a whole life transformation last
year
rebel shared her story on instagram live
revealing that she reached her
165 pound goal weight
and the real reason she took steps to
center
2020 on health the goal was never
to be skinny it was um
it was never to fit into a certain dress
size
i i put a goal weight on there because
you know i needed some tangible thing
but i am really glad
that i did it because
[Music]
i think it was time like i'd been i'd
been overweight for about 20 years
just before her year of health rebel
explained to et
how working on the set of cats caused
some unexpected weight loss
i lost eight pounds shooting my number
in four days
one because of yeah there's a lot of
physicality when you see the film um but
also
they heated up the set very hot to
almost 100
fahrenheit why um so that we could never
cool down
because for dancers these people are
like the best dancers in the whole
world so they can't cool their muscles
down they could get an injury
so they would heat up the set like a
sauna so we would never cool down but it
made it pretty uncomfortable the
australian actress
also revealed an unconventional workout
she
invented well i did invent something
called cats the size
uh on my instagram yeah because for my
birthday
my friend surprised me with a dance
class two caps
great way to burn calories guys dancing
around as a cat
bloody brilliant get into it